Nigeria has the highest rate of identical
twins.
China has the lowest rate at only 1 in 300
births being twins.
Polar bears most commonly give birth to twins.
22% of twins are left handed, compared to
only 10% of non-twins.
Researchers suspect that 1 in 8 people start
life as a twin but because of miscarriages
of one of the fetuses, only 1 in 70 people
are actually born twins.
That's all very interesting but...
What Actually Causes Twins?
There are two types of "Multiple Pregnancy",
identical and fraternal.
Identical or monozygotic twins occur when
one egg is fertilised by one sperm and the
fertilised egg splits into two or more embryos.
Scientists believe identical twins happen
purely by chance and there are no contributing
factors, such as age, race or family genes.
One quarter of all twins are "mirror twins",
caused by a late split of the fertilised egg.
This is when the twins are direct reflections
of each other.
One will always be left handed and the other
will always be right handed.
If one has a birthmark on the left side of
their face the other will have the same birthmark
on the right side, and so on.
But the reflection is more than skin deep,
one of the twins will have their internal
organs on the wrong side of their body, so
their heart will beat on the right side.
On the other hand fraternal or dizygotic twins
runs in the family.
Fraternal pregnancy happens when two or more
eggs are fertilised by different sperm.
Women can inherit a certain gene which causes
them to hyper-ovulate, meaning she is more
likely to release multiple eggs during ovulation.
Therefore, increasing the chance of a multiple
pregnancy.
So if anyone in your family has twins, or
you yourself are a twin, you're much more
likely to have twins yourself.
The Rate of Twins is Increasing Dramatically
The birth rate of twins has increased by 76%
since 1980.
In 1980 one in every 53 babies was a twin,
however today, one in every 30 babies born
is a twin.
Which, when you think about it, is an awful
lot of twins.
But what caused such an upsurge?
One of the biggest factor is that the average
age of women having children has risen, and
the older the mother is, the more likely she
is to give birth to twins.
Another contributing factor is a rapid increase
in the use of fertility treatments that promote
the release of multiple eggs during ovulation.
But enough of that, let's get onto the really
bizarre stuff...
There's a "Twin Town"
A small town in Brazil, Cândido Godói is
the twin capital of the world.
Amongst the 80 families that live in the town,
there are 38 pairs of twins.
Some believe there's something in the water
that's causing such such an astronomically
high number of twin births.
But others think there's something much more
sinister going on.
Researchers have suggested it may have been
caused by a Nazi physician called Josef Mengele,
who had the nickname "Angel of Death".
It has been said that during the 1960s, when
the explosion of twins in the town first occurred,
Mengele was performing experiments on the
women of the town, involving strange new drugs
and even artificial insemination.
Identical Twins, Aren't Identical
All identical twins have distinguishable qualities
from birth.
After all identical twins do have different
DNA, their DNA is extremely similar but not
identical.
Identical twins also have completely different
sets of fingerprints.
Twins Have Their Own Language
"Idioglossia" is a language shared between
twins, that only they understand.
About 40% of twins invent their own language,
it sounds complete gibberish to me and you
but it's a close bond shared between the siblings.
This phenomenon can also occur between very
close siblings, but more commonly twins.
Their shared language usually disappears by
the time they start school.
How Different Can Twins Be?
Very.
Twins can be different genders, but even more
astonishing, twins can be different ages.
Recently there was a case where 5 year old
Reuben Blake got a brand new twin sister.
Even though they have 5 years between them,
they are still, technically twins.
Their mother had difficulty getting pregnant
naturally so she turned to In vitro fertilisation
(IVF).
This is when the eggs are fertilised outside
of the body then re-implanted into the woman's
uterus.
But Reuben's mother only had two of the embryos
from the process implanted into her uterus,
the other three were frozen.
A few years later she had the remaining embryos
implanted and 9 months later she gave birth
to Reuben's twin sister.
Believe it or not twins can have different
dads and be different races.
It's rare, but about 2% of fraternal twins
have different dads.
This happens when a woman releases two eggs
during ovulation and then gets impregnated
by two different men at the same time.
Twins Bond in the Belly
We've all witnessed the unbreakable bond that
twins often have, but where does it come from?
Twins actually bond physically in the womb.
Researchers at the University of Padova in
Italy noticed via 3D ultrasound that at 14
weeks old, fetuses reach out for each other
in the womb.
At 18 weeks old they were stroking each other
and maintained physical contact 30% of the
time.
Strangely, in these tests the fetuses avoided
touching each other's eyes, as if they know
it's a delicate area.
So now you know all about twins, but the story
I'm about to share with you will blow your
mind, introducing...
The Twin Jims
The prize for the most incredible twin story
has to go to Jim Lewis and Jim Springer.
They were born in 1940 and adopted by separate
families in Ohio.
They grew up 45 miles from each other and
had no contact for 39 years.
When they were reunited in 1979 they discovered
that they were both named James by their adoptive
parents, they both married twice, first to
women named Linda and secondly to women named
Betty.
They both had children, Jim Springer had a
boy whom he named James Allan and Jim Lewis
named his son James Alan, with one L. They
both had dogs named Toy.
They both drank the same beer, smoked the
same cigarettes and drove the same model of
car, Chevrolets.
Their medical histories were identical and
they shared the same hobbies, including a
woodworking workshop in both their garages.
They both had vacations on the exact same
beach in Florida.
Simply incredible.